I've spent a lot of time in my career
defending the institution of marriage
and I defend it because it's the Bedrock
of civilization so it deserves defending
and I defend it because it's under
constant attack so it needs defending
and one of the most troubling
developments in recent years which we've
discussed on the show in the past is
that these attacks are increasingly
waged not just from the left but from
certain noisy segments of the right as
well some right-wing influencers with
Legions of young mostly male fans had
decided that men should abandon marriage
and family life and go their own way and
these these influencers many of whom
consider themselves a part of the
so-called red pill movement pretend to
despise feminists and yet have
essentially arrived at the same
conclusion as feminists which is that we
should give up on the family the two
sides hate marriage almost as much as
they hate each other
now one of these influencers is a woman
named Pearl Davis who has garnered a
relatively large following on YouTube
and various social media platforms uh
she's in her mid-20s single and
childless and Yet full of opinions about
modern marriage and family life a
subject that she has no personal insight
into whatsoever she spent the past few
days on the internet complaining about
quote unquote Trad cons like myself who
she says promote the nuclear family
despite not understanding what it's
really like yes we men who actually have
wives and children don't know what it's
like to be married but a woman who is
not married and has no children does
know what it's like in one of her tweets
she wrote the tradecons push marriage
because they aren't old enough to know
better they don't know the reality of
what they're pushing this is accompanied
by a picture of myself Ben Shapiro
Michael Knowles we aren't old enough to
know better and don't know the reality
of what we're pushing yet a woman who is
younger than us and single does know
better and does understand this reality
another post she goes on to say that
marriage is a terrible deal for men and
she later explains quote would you ever
sign a contract that fails 75 percent of
the time where your business partner is
paid to break the contract why would you
encourage men to sign that contract
until the terms are fixed now
you may be surprised to learn that
marriages fail at a rate of 75 percent
the figure that people like this
normally use is 50 and the claim that 50
of marriages end in divorce is already
spurious and we'll have more on that in
a moment but 75 percent
I was wondering where that number came
from so I scrolled down and I saw
something that she reposted from an
alleged lawyer who said this quote it's
not 50 50. that only accounts for
divorces another 25 percent on the
negative side for miserable men trapped
in Cheaper to Keep Her marriages
unwilling to risk Financial destruction
and loss of their children
75 percent chance of a devastatingly bad
outcome is just a bad plan no sane
person would enter into a commercial
contract on such terms
now I did ask him where he got this 75
figure from and he wouldn't say
apparently the magic statistic fairy
came and whispered it in his ear now for
her Park Pearl later tweeted a picture
of Pierce Brosnan with his wife of 20
years and she questioned whether the
marriage counts as successful since
Brosnan Brosnan's wife has put on some
weight at the age of 60.
so apparently even if they're happy and
have remained married for two decades
they still might fall into that 75
failure rate because they have not both
remained in supermodel condition into
their 60s
this debate on social media brought out
the rest of the marriage skeptical crowd
on the right a bunch of these uh red
pill influencers decided to hop on an
emergency Zoom call and spend two hours
talking about me and the rest of the
daily wire crew and our Reckless
promotion of society's most fundamental
institution now there's there's one clip
here that you should see this is um
uh apparently a divorce a divorce lawyer
who says that the failure rate for
marriage is not 50 and it's not 75 it is
in fact even higher less
I think marriage can be successful of
course it's just not something that's as
scalable as we as a society are trying
to pretend it is marriage is and I've
said this a hundred times and I'll say
it 100 more marriages like the lottery
you are probably not going to win okay
you're probably not going to win don't
make that your 401k you're probably not
gonna win but if you win what you win is
so great that I don't blame you for
buying a ticket and trying I personally
don't buy lottery tickets but when
somebody says yeah I play the lottery
hey man Somebody's gotta win and you
know what as long as you're not blowing
money that you need for food or to put
shoes on your kids feet you're not
hurting anybody go out give it a try so
I always tell people listen marriage
when it works when you have somebody
who's married 20 plus years and they're
still crazy about each other that is the
exception not the rule but when you do
it it's phenomenal it's phenomenal so
why not buy the ticket take the ride but
have a prenup where seat belt guys you
can be a safe driver but wear a seat
belt
so a happy marriage he says is like
winning a lottery and the thing about
the lottery is that almost everybody
loses this is a perfect summation of how
this entire Club views marriage and the
message that they're uh sending to young
men in particular
sure it can be great they concede but
only if you're insanely lucky everybody
else is screwed
this this is a rather Bleak view of
marriage and thankfully it's also
nonsense
first of all the claim that marriage
isn't scalable
is obviously ridiculous because marriage
has served as the Bedrock of human
society since time immemorial
it has already happened at the scale of
civilization for thousands of years
now the divorce lawyers come along and
say that you know this thing that
Society has been doing forever turns out
it doesn't work
unless you're the one in a million
it's it's ridiculous it's a ridiculous
claim
now what about the failure rate of
marriages in our culture we've heard 50
we've heard 75 percent we just heard
that they they fail at a rate similar to
the rate that people lose the lottery
which would mean higher than 99 a lot
higher
um yeah
these kinds of astronomical odds are not
based in anything but the Doom and Gloom
speculations of the people inventing
them
there is no evidence that having a happy
marriage is as unlikely as winning the
lottery or that 75 percent of marriages
end in misery
and what about the 50 number well this
is at least is a is a familiar statistic
it's it's something that you've probably
heard before 50 of marriages end in
divorce
um it's familiar but it is bogus
and one way you you know that it's bogus
is that people have been claiming that
50 of marriages end in divorce since I
was a kid
I've been hearing that my whole life
and that would mean that divorce rates
are static across time but of course
that isn't the case in fact we know that
divorce rates have gone down in recent
years
so so where does the 50 figure come from
apparently it's a it's a holdover from
the 1980s which is when people first
started citing that statistic it's not
true today
and it's actually not clear that it was
true even in the in the 80s either
so what is the actual divorce rate
um it's a little bit hard to determine
probably our best guess is based on U.S
census data which according to the most
recent figures says that about 35
percent of American adults who have been
married have been divorced
so it's not exactly going to give us a
precisely scientific figure of what the
divorce rate is but it's it's as close
as we're going to get 35 percent
and 35 is High I mean it's way too high
it's not 50 though and it's not 75 and
it's not 99 percent
and it's definitely not Lottery odds
still isn't it terrifying to think that
if you get married your chance of
failure is 35 and the chance of success
is only 65 percent at the most
you know even if we go with that number
isn't that still very very scary
isn't it high enough that it should
dissuade anyone from attempting it
the answer to that question is no
and here's why
if the divorce rate is 35 percent
or even if it's 50 percent
it does not follow that your own
particular marriage has a 35 or 50
percent chance of failure now I'm not
saying that you should be cocky or
Reckless or that you should see yourself
as invincible
I am saying that you shouldn't On The
Other Extreme
see yourself as passive debris floating
helplessly on the tide of statistical
likelihoods
because you are an individual your
marriage is an individual thing
and its chances of failure are not set
by Society at Large
so here's an example to illustrate what
I mean
and this is really really important
to understand because because as
marriage rates fall and those are
falling
um you know the the thing that that
convinces so many people to not marry in
the first place are numbers like this
and this this misconception that well
look at the divorce rate and that is my
own specific chance of getting divorced
and and I'm here to tell you that's not
how it works
well you know a company's looking out
for you when they actually upgrade your
service and don't charge you for it this
is great news for new and current Pure
Talk customers pure talk just added data
to every plan and includes a mobile
hotspot with no price increase
whatsoever if you've considered uh pure
talk before but you haven't made the
switch take a look again for just 20 a
month you'll get unlimited talk text and
now 50 more 5G data plus their new
mobile hotspot that's why I love
puretalk they are veteran owned they
only hire the best customer service team
located right here in the great USA most
families are saving almost a thousand
dollars a year while enjoying the most
Dependable 5G Network in America
remember you vote with how you spend
your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that don't support
you when you go to puretalk.com Walsh
you'll save an additional 50 off your
first month because they actually value
you that's puretalk.com walls Pure Talk
Wireless for Americans by Americans
so here's I think this illustrates it
the obesity rate in the United States is
over 40 percent
does that mean that your own chances of
becoming obese are forty percent no it
doesn't
your chances might be five percent they
might be practically zero
or they might be quite a bit higher than
40 percent
that's because obesity is the result of
behavior and choices
if you do not engage in the behavior or
make the choices that lead to obesity
you will not become obese
the fact that 40 of people around you
are fat does not mean that you
automatically have a 40 obesity risk
now let's take another example
car accidents Americans get into car
accidents at a certain rate I'm not sure
what the rate is it doesn't matter for
our purposes what does matter is that
your own individual chance of getting
into a car accident is not the same as
every other driver on the road the
people who compile statistics will say
things like motorists have an X percent
chance of getting into a collision
but you are not just a generic motorist
you are an individual
now you can never bring your own chance
of dying in a fiery car wreck down to
zero
but if you're responsible if you're a
responsible driver then obviously your
chances of getting into an accident are
much lower than the chances of someone
who is not responsible
all of those stupid drivers who don't
understand the basic rules of the road
and like to tweet and eat while they
drive and and everything else they're
inflating the numbers for everyone
they're now they're also making the
roads more dangerous for everyone
you know they are actually actively
making your own chances of getting into
a car accident higher because the roads
are filled with stupid people
but your chances are not as high as
their chances
you do not share their level of risk
unless you're as dumb as they are
because again you are an individual not
a mere statistic
so what about marriage
it's true
that even if you do everything right
things can still fall apart if your
spouse doesn't follow that program
now if you both do everything right or
even most things right
then your chance of divorce is basically
zero
but you can do everything on your end
and maybe your spouse doesn't do the
same and then it falls apart anyway and
that happens and it's terrible but it
happens
it's also true that there are many many
things you can do in your marriage and
before your marriage to make it much
more secure than the average
obvious things
like you can marry someone who shares
your same fundamental values not
everyone does that in fact a lot of
people don't a lot of people go into
marriages knowing ahead of time that
they're marrying someone who doesn't
share their fundamental values
their their div their chances of divorce
are going to be somewhere much higher
than yours if you don't make that basic
entry-level mistake that they have made
you can do other things like you can
state from the outset that you both in
principle don't believe in divorce and
won't consider it as a viable option for
solving any marital difficulties you may
experience down the line you could have
a strong and shared faith
you can establish from the beginning a
habit of honest communication you can
make time for each other you can
continue to date even or especially as
your lives get busier and you start
having kids and so on you can make a
strong effort to be patient with and
grateful to each other you can take care
of your body and your appearance you can
do all these things and more now I'm not
saying that if you do all of this it
will bring your divorce chance down to
zero I'm not denying that there are
plenty of people out there who who did
all this at least on their own end and
yet still ended up divorced that's not
my point my point is that the divorce
rate doesn't take any of that into
account
the people who take none of these basic
steps are lumped in with the people who
do all of it and we're supposed to
believe that both groups have an equal
chance of marital failure that's just
not true
now
I don't deny that there are real serious
problems with marriage in our society
the so-called red pill people and others
they race totally legitimate and
important points on that end we need
drastic reform abolish no fault divorce
the entire family court system has to be
torn down and rebuilt the system is
stacked against men in many ways that
are extremely unfair and have ruined
countless lives so let's fight for those
reforms absolutely but this systemic
problem
is not going to be solved today or
tomorrow or next week
abolishing no-fault divorce is just the
beginning of reforming the system
lawmakers in a small number of red
states have only just started to
seriously consider that idea which is
merely step one so we're a long way off
from fixing the system it took decades
to get us here it will take decades to
get us out at best
anyone who tells you anything else is
selling you something
they're selling you a bill of goods
this is this is a decade-long long-term
struggle
is what are young men young people in
general supposed to do in the meantime
and this is where the red pill becomes
more of a hazy foggy ambiguous pill they
have no answer they simply shot about
reforms that are needed yet have nothing
to say to the young men in our culture
today
who will be old if not dead by the time
the system is fixed if it's ever fixed
at all
what are these young men supposed to do
right now what kind of life would you
have them lead right now today
the answer it appears is that an entire
generation of young men if not multiple
Generations Should Skip marriage while
we wait for the system to improve
but this is not a viable solution it's
not a solution at all it's a surrender
you're asking entire generations to give
up their bloodline their legacy their
chance of finding the Transcendent joy
and meaning that family life can provide
you're asking them to give up on
themselves and on civilization itself
for thousands of years human beings have
always understood that their most basic
purpose and obligation was to form
families and have children
and yet you're telling these young men
to ignore this calling and do what
instead live for themselves alone
wasting away in front of screens
only to die with no descendants leaving
no lasting mark on the world
think about the kind of misery you're
consigning these men to think about the
catastrophic probably fatal effect this
would have on our country
you can't give up on propagating the
species for a few decades and then pick
it back up again like nothing happened
that doesn't work on any level
individually or societally it is a
recipe for despair and collapse
am I saying that young men
and women
should accept the risk then and get
married anyway
yes that's exactly what I'm saying that
doesn't mean you should be Reckless I've
already talked about many practical
things you can do to mitigate your own
risk so that it's not a roll of the dice
you should do all those things don't go
into marriage blind
but don't run from it either
even if you mitigate the risk to the
extent possible still there will be a
risk that's true but but here's the rub
all good things come with risk
the more worthwhile it is the worse and
more disastrous it will be if you fail
if you take on more responsibility then
your life will be more consequential and
the more consequential your life is the
more cataclysmic your failures
potentially become
a married man with children lives a life
of Greater consequence than a single man
with no children
there are more people depending on him
he has a greater stake in the future
this means that if things go sideways
it'll be a tragedy if he screws up or
his wife screws up or they both do his
life will be ruined his children will be
devastated
and the impact will reverberate down
through the generations this is what it
means to live a high impact
consequential life
these are the stakes
and yes they are quite High
now
sure you can
Stave off that sort of catastrophe by
staying by yourself never going out on a
limb never taking any risk never
marrying never having kids
never striving for anything great or
meaningful in life
but then you're not avoiding failure and
misery you are guaranteeing it
you are ensuring that you never lose
your family in a divorce by never having
a family to lose in the first place
which is like ensuring that you never go
bankrupt by being bankrupt to begin with
I'm not going to lose all my money
because I'm going to stay broke I beat
the system
not losing by having nothing to lose is
a loss in itself
and I don't want that for anyone
it's not a path to happiness and
prosperity for either you or Society
it is a path to defeat a preemptive and
self-imposed defeat
and that is the worst kind of all
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code walls
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there